- Please welcome to the
show, our dear friend,
Danny Pellegrino.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
- [Danny] Excited to be here.
- [Drew] Thanks.
And you've been published a lot of times,
but this is all you.
- Yeah, I was a ghost writer
before, so this is my first
collection of stories, so it
was so creatively fulfilling
'cause as a ghost writer, you
write in someone else's voice,
so it was so exciting to tell my stories,
and I wanted the book
to feel like a warm hug
when you read it, and
so I hope people laugh,
I hope they enjoy it.
I think we all need our laughs
where we can get them now.
So there's tons of pop
culture, there's nostalgia.
There's a couple more
dramatic moments too.
- What's your favorite pop
culture story in there?
- The stories always change.
My brain just thinks in pop culture.
There was one birthday story
that I wrote about in the book.
My boyfriend and I had
been together forever,
and I'm not a big birthday person.
We like to go to the
movies on my birthday.
And a few years ago we went to the movies
and Jonathan Groff.
(Drew sighs)
- I mean, he's great, right?
- I love him.
- He was with Lea Michele,
both Broadway people.
I think they were sitting in front of me,
so in my head the whole
time we're watching,
"A star is born" All I'm thinking is like,
my boyfriend planned them to come sing
happy birthday to me afterwards.
So I'm sitting in, "A star is born"
Practicing my excited
face for when they get up
after the movie to sing happy birthday.
Which was crazy, and that's
not what they were there for.
And I got mad at my boyfriend
then when I finally realized
that they weren't there to sing to me.
I don't know what happened
in, "A star is born."
I've obviously seen the original,
I need to rewatch it, but
it was like, you know,
you build things up, and
birthdays make us crazy, I think.
We build things up in our
heads, we have such expectation.
And so, you know, it's a little
more detailed in the book,
but yeah, I thought these
Broadway people were there
to sing heavy birthday, which is insane.
And then I got mad at my
boyfriend for not doing that.
They're not for hire.
Jonathan Groff's not
like, he's not a clown.
- You do mingle with fabulous people.
I think anything might be
possible in your world, Danny.
But did you forgive him?
- No.
(Drew and Ross laughing)
- I love it.
All right, well it's design week here,
and when are Drew crew design
hero, Mikel Welch was here,
he said the 90's are
coming back in home decor,
and Danny, since you practically got a PhD
in pop culture nostalgia,
we thought that we could dig
into some stories where
design and nostalgia meet.
Are you in?
- I'm so excited.
- Okay, perfect.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
All right, Danny, you're the first story.
- Okay, so first up, some
people invest in Bitcoin,
other people invest in Britney Spears.
That's a currency I can get behind.
The New York post reports a super fan
named Zachary Gordon
Abraham has spent 20 years
building a Britney bunker in his house.
We're talking wall to
wall Brit collectibles.
I love that, and it's now-
- [Drew] Oh, it gets better, look at that.
- [Danny] It's now-
- [Drew] Can you believe that?
- [Danny] I'd say undervalued at $137,000.
- [Drew] I agree!
- And that's not all,
Zachary even met his husband
through their love of Britney Spears.
Who doesn't love Britney Spears?
- I love that he met his partner.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
- I know.
- And I get it too.
I'm a pop culture collectible person,
so I have my, the nanny
Barbie at my house.
- Oh my God.
- The Fran Drescher?
- I love Fran Drescher.
I have a Rosie O'Donnell Barbie.
Remember she had?
We need to get, do you have a Barbie?
Charlie's angels Barbie.
- We have Charlie's angels dolls, yeah.
- Well this guy wanted to stop
collecting Britney's stuff
but he bought one more,
and you know what he said?
"Oops, I did it again."
- Aha!
(crowd applauds)
All right, next we're gonna
go to the shaggadelic 70's.
Insider reports a woman
named Charlie Leanna Murphy
was so inspired by Jayne
Mansfield's pink shag look
that she created her own pink penthouse.
Look at this.
Look, it features pink glittered doors
and shag, shag, shag everywhere,
and it's not just wall to wall,
it's floor to ceiling too.
- [Drew] Wow.
- [Danny] I feel like I need
a Claritin just looking-
- [Ross] Exactly.
- [Drew] Ironically.
- [Ross] Yeah, well she
says she has to vacuum
every single day to make sure
the air doesn't get too shaggy
and dusty.
Yeah, that's a lot of shag carpet.
- It's funny, my friend, Jamie
Nelson, she's a photographer,
she shoots all of our
flower beauty campaign.
She's amazing.
This is her bathroom.
That is not a joke.
She is the coolest chick on the planet.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
I thought it was her house
that we were talking about
for a minute.
I love when people go for it.
- [Danny] Yeah, totally.
- I love that all in factor.
In fact, staying and moving
to the 1970s for a minute,
the Daily Mail reports, a
young guy in the UK longed
for that perfect cozy 70's feel
of his grandparents' house,
so he totally transformed his living space
into a 1970's cocoon.
- [Ross] So cool.
- He spent, listen $3,000.
I know that sounds like a lot of money,
but he was able to redo his entire house.
He bought everything secondhand
on eBay and Facebook,
and then created this total time warp.
I think he did a fantastic job for-
- [Ross] I love it.
(applause)
- I have this fantasy of doing
like a late 90's inspired,
so I wanna get the inflatable furniture,
and I always had a dream of,
having one of those MacBooks
we never got, do you know
the colorful MacBook?
- Yeah.
- I wanted one of those so bad.
- And like, the full box one?
- My dream, Drew, was to sit
in front of that computer,
watch Charlie's angels on the TV,
and sit on my inflatable furniture.
That's all I want, is a late 90's.
- Danny, I think we
could make this happen.
(upbeat music)